this is my first question because I I
know that you're even raised by single
mom there's a teachers public school
fifth sixth grade she's retired now over
the last couple of years but so she
wants your grandkids more but yes she
she taught public school yeah mine did
too and did when you went to public
school nobody ever did that for me like
Shannon did like her teacher did you
ever have anything like that kind of ass
no no not really I mean I knew because
that was my mother's reason for why
couldn't I can we get the you know the
Star Trek toy - no we can't afford it as
long as we can't afford it so poor
because but but she you know she
definitely well she did have one lesson
that she kind of tried to impart to me
growing up well I really wanted a dog
when I was a kid in the new house in
Boston you know and there's a Bock and
you know pretty normal of Airpark
whatever and my mom said you're not
responsible enough to have a dog I was
ten I was like I am responsible
she said you're right won't you show me
that you can do this you you have to
walk the dog every day twice a day I
said well okay let's get the dog she
goes no first you have to walk an
imaginary dog I was like it's right as
the Wooden's like twice a day around the
block as if you had the dog so I know
that you will do it and you're
responsible enough to do it so this
woman who I hope is watching gave me a
leash and I had to walk around the block
lmd leave and worse we get to three
weeks in and she's like no I forget it
I'm not giving you she taught me the
lesson of disappointment well I didn't
get a dog and I thought I was so
deprived I did like the dumbest thing
you can do which you can that's the kind
of thing you tend to do when you're 18
which is how old I was and as soon as I
moved to LA and said to be an actor and
had no money and no job and lived in a
tiny apartment like on Cherokee and
yucca over there in Hollywood like I was
like I'm getting so
I went out and got a dog not only get a
dog but I got a husky which is like the
most you know they only want to escape
yeah I mean that's dared like mission
and like yeah I quickly realize like oh
you have to get the dog food that kind
of going broke on this dog has sad
ending to the story though which was
that used to leave the dog in a little a
little space shared space in the
apartment when I went out to grab some
outdoor time and got stolen before the
little the microchips and the stuff that
you can put in it you know to track him
down
yeah yes somebody stole a dog but it's
telling that I didn't rush out and get
another dog he probably was not living
his best life with me very happy life on
a farm I did that I did the same thing
though when I was young I was like I I
think you when you're out here because I
moved out here too and you want
companionship or some kind of you can't
be lonely so I did that too it was a
dumb move
yeah when you have the least money the
smallest subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going